[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de votre journal local
voici les trith les titres de ce
mercredi 22 février une première à saint
quentin en yvelines l'agglomération
organisé ce matin une conférence
intercommunal du logement objectif
construire une offre pour tous et
simplifier l'accès aux logements sociaux
la deuxième édition du budget
participatif est lancé à maurepas les
habitants peuvent ainsi proposer des
projets communaux qu'il souhaite voir
financer les précisions à suivre dans ce
journal avec le maire de la commune dans
ce journal
également du cinéma avec le réalisateur
nicolas boukhrief qui présentait en
avant première son nouveau film à
versailles la confession une histoire
d'amour compliquée entre un homme
d'église et une femme communiste athée
mais on ouvre ce journal avec de la
politique et l'actualité la plus récente
la plus récente l'annoncent il ya
quelques minutes par françois bayrou le
président du modem 60 du président du
modem excusez moi de ne pas se
représenter à l'élection présidentielle
il a proposé une alliance à emmanuel
macron candidats en marche à la
présidentielle une alliance justement
proposé et accepté il ya quelques
secondes par le candidat emmanuel macron
pour réagir à cette actualité la plus
récente nous sommes en direct par
téléphone avec bruno myle yens le
président du modem dans les yvelines
bruno millièmes bonsoir bonsoir
cette annonce faite par françois bayroux
de vouloir se rapprocher des manuels
macro qui vient justement de dire qu'il
était positif et qu'il acceptait
justement cette alliance proposé par
françois bayrou
c'est une bonne surprise pour vous est
ce que vous saviez vous à titre
personnel que ça allait se passer comme
ça pour françois bayroux je ne dirais
pas plus à titre personnel je le savais
je trouve d'abord que se tuent ils
annoncent excessivement courageux houten
de responsabilité de la part de françois
bayrou on a bien vu au cours des
derniers mois entre les affaires un
candidat de gauche de noix mots pour
lequel j'ai le plus grand respect mais
qui est quand même le candidat de la
gauche qui est l'opposant au président
sortant un peu parti socialiste ouvrier
bien qu'il ya quelque chose qui ne
marche pas dans le royaume des grands
partis donc nous ça fait très longtemps
ça c'est très très longtemps que
françois porte ce message d'un
rassemblement en france de toutes les
forces pour ressortir le pays avec de la
france et d'avoir un axe central qui
puisse gouverner en étant en utilisant
cette intelligence de tout le monde et
pas seulement ma camp contre l'autre et
je pense que françois a pris une
décision excessivement responsable plein
d'animations et qui peut redonner
énormément de sport c'est un tournant
décisif selon vous dans cette campagne
présidentielle c'est une possible marche
vers la victoire pour pour emmanuel
macron selon vous avez en tout cas on
nous on va mettre toutes les forces
disponibles pour y aller parce que c'est
une occasion la deuxième depuis 2007 de
pouvoir faire 20 faire gagner un max de
centrales en france plutôt que de voir
encore une fois les républicains face au
très rapidement bruno myle yens comment
ça va se passer par exemple dans le
département des yvelines vous allez
directement rentrer en contact avec le
mouvement en marche départementale des
contacts avec le mouvement en marche
départementale parce qu'on en avait déjà
un petit peu
de toute façon parce que cela fait
partie de notre boulot de discuter de
tout le monde
et effectivement on va recevoir assez
rapidement pour s'organiser merci pour
cette réaction bruno milian je rappelle
que vous êtes le président du modem 78
en politique toujours le parti
socialiste dévoile de son côté peu à peu
ses candidats pour les élections
législatives dans les yvelines
aujourd'hui c'est à mme rose a dû ward
conseiller municipal d'opposition à
vélizy-villacoublay qui a présenté sa
candidature à la presse sur la 2e
circonscription des yvelines une
circonscription qui comprend notamment
les villes de voisins-le-bretonneux et
magny-les-hameaux détenu actuellement
par pascal thévenot le maire de vélizy
villacoublay est historiquement par la
droite
écoute
et à ce propos le candidat socialiste au
micro de patrick jacques de dixmude
je pense qu'il est absolument essentiel
d'être le candidat du rassemblement
le rassemblement de l'ensemble des
forces progressistes puisqu'on à une
droite qui est relativement forte
une extrême droite qui montrent très
très fortement sur la circonscription et
je veux faire un front commun voilà
contre des visions de la société que que
je ne défends pas je ne défends pas le
fait de monter les français les uns
contre les autres moi je suis pour la
solidarité le vivre ensemble la justice
sociale c'est l'une des conséquences de
la loi allure sur l'accession au
logement une conférence intercommunale
sur la thématique était organisé pour la
première fois par l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines aujourd'hui
des élus de l'agglomération ont débattu
sur le sujet pour tenter de définir une
politique commune les détails avec
michael ennemis devront adopter une
stratégie pour mieux répartir les
logements sociaux sur saint quentin en
yvelines à l'objectif de la première
conférence intercommunal organisé ce
mercredi 22 février attrape par les
douze communes du territoire
les représentants se sont réunis pour
débattre de ce thème qui concernent 33
8% des logements sur le secteur c'est
important parce qu'il s'agit de l'avenir
de notre territoire et comment on veut
équilibrer le peuplement de nos
logements
donc ça intéresse les douze communes de
cette agglomération et ça nous oblige à
travailler ensemble pour pour équilibrer
notre territoire en terme de logement
aujourd'hui les logements sociaux sont
principalement concentrés sur deux
communes trappe élus en cours qui
représente 43 % du parc social de saint
quentin en yvelines
la finalité en fait de cette conférence
est de mettre au point une stratégie de
peuplement en semble commune qui fasse
que toutes les personnes qui attribue
des logements ce qu'on appelle les
réservataires s'y conforment
pour je dirais ne pas continuer à
concentrer les difficultés au même
endroit voilà où dans la même cage
d'escalier de nouvelles conférences sur
ce thème seront organisées par saint
quentin en yvelines dans les prochains
mois pour définir une stratégie commune
à 5 à saint quentin en yvelines toujours
la ville de maurepas vient de lancer la
deuxième édition de son budget
participatif les habitants jusqu'au 1er
mars pour proposer via le site internet
de la commune un projet qu'il souhaite
voir financer dans la limite d'un budget
de 150 mille euros l'an passé 70 projets
ont été proposés par les maures passe
bien ce nouveau budget participatif est
une première dans les yvelines écouter
sur ce sujet le maire les républicains
de la ville grégory hagard et astier
l'objectif aussi de ce budget
participatif c'est de réaliser des
équipements ou des actions sur la ville
auquel même les élus n'aura pas pensé
donc c'est ouvert ça peut concerner la
petite enfance ça peut concerner
l'environnement ça peut concerner le
sport et c'est donc tous les projets
sont les sur les bienvenus évidemment
dans la limite de leur faisabilité
technique mais aussi et dans le maximum
de leur lot de 50000 euros prévus une
mauvaise nouvelle à présent pour le
secteur touristique francilien avec les
chiffres définitifs 2016 dévoilé par le
comité régional du tourisme et des
chiffres qui confirment la baisse
envisagée par les professionnels avec
par exemple le nombre de visiteurs
étrangers en chute de près de 9% l'an
passé par rapport à 2015
au total la région parisienne a perdu
1,25 million de touristes ont un an soit
une perte économique évalué à 1,3
milliard d'euros
évidemment ce mauvais bilan touche
également les sites les plus
emblématiques de la banlieue comme le
château de versailles qui a vu
lui sa fréquentation baisser de 10% sur
un an
dans un tout autre registre nous vous
présentons à présent un témoignage
émouvant celui de jacqueline fleury
déportés et résistants durant la seconde
guerre mondiale elle nous a ouvert les
portes de son appartement à versailles
pour nous raconter son histoire à 94 ans
elle fait partie des dernières personnes
vivantes qui ont résisté pendant
l'occupation allemande
un témoignage poignant recueillis par
alice deschamps et mathieu de 2 min en
1942 sous la france occupée la jeune
versaillaise jacqueline fleury âgé de 20
ans entre en résistance avec sa famille
elle distribuer tracts journaux
clandestins participent à des réseaux de
renseignement et prend chaque jour de
plus en plus de risques
quand je rentrais de paris avec mon
petit chargement de journaux clandestins
on pouvait être arrêté dans le métro
dans les rues dans les gares dont les
gars surtout il y avait la police
française la police allemande pour nous
la gestapo arrêté justement jacques une
fleury letang février 1944 dans son
appartement versaillais elle est alors
envoyé avec sa famille à la prison de
fresnes puis déporté en allemagne
s'ensuivent sept jours de transfert
confiné dans un wagon direction le camp
de concentration de ravensbrück
nous recevions un numéro puisque à
partir de cet instant nous n'étions plus
des êtres humains
nous étions des chic c'est à dire des
morceaux là c'est la négation de
l'humain dans cette indication de
lettres en l'espace d'un an jacqueline
changera trois fois de camp et
travaillera pour l'armurerie allemande
en tant que prisonnière en 1945 elle
s'évade avec sa mère et deux autres
détenus
elles seront rapatriés en france par
l'armée rouge comme on avait toujours
vécu par terre je trouvais les bords des
trottoirs extraordinaire ça m'attirait
pour m'asseoir et j'entends j'entendrai
toujours ma mère me dire mais tu ne peux
pas faire fin nous sommes à versailles
un témoignage douloureux que cette
résistante retrace depuis plus de
soixante dix ans aux enfants dans les
collèges et lycées un devoir de mémoire
que jacqueline continue de perpétuer
pour transmettre son héritage culturel
aux nouvelles générations au fond quand
on a peut-être très dans un camp c'est
aussi quelque chose que je dis aux
enfants que je rencontre le professeur
évidemment on ne sort jamais
complètement dingue quand il n'y a pas
un jour où on ne retrouve pas quelque
chose comptait les jours depuis sept
depuis ce depuis 2005
ou bien se fait le jour sans compter
tout ce qu'on a laissé toutes nos
compagnes tous styles et tous qu'on rit
on n'a encore aucune dent caire et
sachez d'ailleurs que vous pouvez
retrouver le témoignage de jacqueline
fleuri dans un ouvrage intitulé une
famille du refus mais toujours
l'espérance
on referme ce journal avec du cinéma et
le réalisateur nicolas boukhrief qui se
plongent dans l'amour et la religion
avec son nouveau film la confession une
adaptation du livre léon morin prêtre de
béatrice beck l histoire d'amour entre
un prêtre et une communiste athée le
réalisateur était hier au cirano de
versailles pour une avant première
rencontre avec camille lambert et les
commet
il est jeune c'est surtout sa voix que
j'ai apprécié
lorsque vous montez d'hommes qu'il
arrive à tous vous assumez comme ça
c'est tout
l'arrivée d'un nouveau prêtre dans une
petite villa passe rarement inaperçu
surtout s'il est charismatique léon
morin hommes d'église séduisant et d'art
ni communistes athées deux personnages
que tout semble opposer
il ya quelque chose de suspect amoureux
et une tension vraiment une tension
amoureuse
c'est un film sur quelle voie prendre
d'amour pour s'exprimer bon comment
commandes de personnes peuvent se
rencontrer
quand les interdits sont absolus la
question c'est une serre en cascade
amour parce que c'est un amour qui doit
être terrestre au stade amour qu'il va
être autrement
il tape appareils différents au début c
mais au final et comme tous ses
semblables
ce qu'ils voulaient c'était moins mettre
à genoux une adaptation du roman de
béatrice beck mûri par le cinéaste
depuis 20 ans contrairement aux livres
plus centré sur le prêtre le film se
veut un portrait de femme incarnée par
marine vacth qui m'a vraiment intéressé
c'est un début de la v 24 ans à l'époque
c'est une immense maturité et une
qualité d'écouté remarquable et je me
suis dit pour un film cas autant le
texte qui suit cela vous jude verbal le
fait qu'elle puisse autant écouter des
premiers rendez-vous quand je lui
parlais du rôle et tout ça je trouve
qu'elle écoutait qu'une attention énorme
j'ai le sentiment que marine brest et
romain duris ça fonctionne parfaitement
il était totalement harmonieux ils ont
trouvé tout de suite le teint peau de
leurs échanges et ça a été un tournage
de ce point de vue là qu'ils avaient une
forme de grâce une élégance qui se
retrouvent sur grand écran les deux
protagonistes noue une relation à la
fois complice et complexe un drame
d'époque sur fond d'occupation allemande
à découvrir en salles le 8 mars
on dira que c'est le diable qui vous
avez un croche-patte fin de ce 7 8 le
journal nos reportages sont à retrouver
sur notre site internet tv fil 78 points
comme bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]